اظهر مقطع فيديو متداول في تايوان لحظات
صعبه مر فيها مسافرين علامه طائره كانت
متجهه من تايوان الى سنغافوره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الدخان اللي شفته داخل مكسوره الطائره
سببه حريق والحريق سبب الشاحن متنقل او
باور بانك كان مع احد المسافرين وارتفعت
حرارته وانفجر في اللحظات الاولى
للاستعداد الطائره للاقلاع وتسبب في جروح
طفيفه لحامل الباور بانك وصديقه اللي جالس
جنبه وبعد الانفجار اللي صار تم التعامل
مع الموقف من قبل طبعا طواقيم الطيران
اللي موجودين وتم فراغ الطائره من الركاب
وفحصها بشكل دقيق وبعدين عادت واكملت
رحلتها الى سنغافوره هذه الحادثه بتخلينا
نفكر يعني كثير في التحذيرات اللي بتطلقها
شركات الطيران عن المواد المحظوره في
المقصوره واللي من بينها الباور بانك اللي
في حالات انفجار وبتشكل خطر على كثير من
مستخدمينه ففي شركه طيران بتمنع منعبات
اصطحاب الباور بانكوا اجهزه الشحن
المتنقله في مكسوره التيارات لكن في شركات
بتسمح بوضعها مع الراكب صوره الطيران
الداخلي ولكن مثلا بتشترط شروط معينه مثل
انه يكون سعى معين عموما ومؤخرا ومع كثره
الاجهزه اللي بنستخدمها صارت كل الناس
تقريبا يعني بتشيل شواحن وتنقله وتضارب
قوانين شركات الطيران بخصوصها مربك صراحه
ومخيف خلينا نحكي في الموضوع اكثر ونفهم
اكثر من كابتن محمود القطه طيار وخبير
سلامه جويه اهلا فيك معنا يا كابتن اذا
تقدر تشرح لنا في الحاله مثلا اللي صارت
الان هذه على الطياره ايش ممكن يكون صار
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى كل الساده
المشاهدين هو طبعا حادث عارض وجديد من
نوعه وهنحتاج دراسات كثير لكن واضح جدا ان
هناك ماسك كهربائي حصل بين الشاحن المتنقل
وواضح جدا يعني من الدراسه المبدئيه
بالشكل المبدئي ان هو تم واصله
بالشاحن الموجود على سياره نفسه وحصل ماس
كهربائي من الاثنين بيبقى ادى الى انفجار
الشارع همم لان كل المؤشرات يعني لا تؤدي
الى ان يحدث اي انفجار للشاحن في الظروف
الطبيعيه يعني على سبيل المثال لو هو
بيستخدمه الراكب وهو بيشحن به تليفون نفسه
هو ما زال على الارض والضغط الجوي لم
يرتفع
بالصعود لا يوجد اي شيء يستدعي ان هو يحدث
هذا الشيء الوحيد المحتمل ان يكون حدث وهو
اقرب الظن ان هو بدا يشحن الشاحن المتنقل
نفسه في ال- همم
الجهاز المعدل الموجود على الطياره او
وسيله الموجوده في الطياره وده متوسط في
كل الطائرات الحديثه دلوقتي سواء مكان عن
طريق اليو اس بي او عن طريق
اللي هي الشاحن العادي طريقه الشحن
العاديه
وواضح ان المس الكهربائي حدث من هنا وهو
ده اللي خلى حصل الحريق او حصل الدخان
مرعب طيب افتراضا لو هذا الكلام كان صار
وهم في الجو
الضيافه الجويه همم انا شفت الفيديو
مع الامر همم الركاب حتى لما كانوا في
حاله ظهره هما قدروا ان هم يبعدوهم علشان
يسمحوا نفسهم ياخذوا المساحه الكافيه
للتعامل مع الامر هو اللي عملوه في هذه
اللحظه هو هو اللي كان هيحصل في الجو
بالضبط بالمناسبه الطياره يعني همم لم
تتاثر بالشكل اللي يخليها همم يبقى فيها
حاله انزعاج او لا تصلح لها همم لكن هو
طبعا بما ان الطياره كانت في الاصل على
الارض فالطيار يعني اثر السلام ولف همم
وعاود اضربه ثاني لكن بالمناسبه يعني
الامر ده لو كان حصل بالطياره طائره ممكن
جدا ما كانش يغير مساره كان ممكن جدا يكمل
الى وجهه الوصول ده بيكون بعد الحريق
الضيافه الجويه هي اللي التقرير
يعني في مطارات او طيران بتروحوا يقول لك
لا لازم تخلي الباور مع العفش في طيران
يقول لك لا لازم تشيلوا في شنطه ايدك معك
على الطياره يعني هذا في تضارب طب مثلا لو
كان في العفش ايش صار هذا الحريق في العفش
ولا الماس
خليني اطمن حضرتك
ان اي دخان او حريق بيحصل في مخزن العفش
يوجد بكل مخازن العفش طفايات حريق بيقدر
الطيار ان هو اولا الطيار عنده اجهزه
انذار بتقول له النشيد دخان او في حريق في
مخزن العفش وهو في طفايات حريق هو بيقدر
فريق همم يعني همم
خبره القياده في بعض الازرار وبعض
التحكمات في هذه تطفيات الحريق بيقدر ان
هو ي- يستخدمها لاطفاء الحريق وبالمناسبه
هم بتبقى اكثر من واحده على حسب نوع
الطياره وهمم هو كمان بيظهر له اذا كان
الحريق تم اطفائه بالكامل امازال مستمر
اذا تم اضافه بالكامل فبيعمل اجراءات او
حتى اذا زال مستمر هو بيقرا بينزل في اقرب
مكان وبيقدر يتعامل معه والطيارين بتتدرب
على ده باجراء دوري كل ست شهور اوكي بس
كيف نفهم التضارب في موضوع انه من شركه
لشركه ومن مطار لمطار بانجال كلام مختلف
انه ساعه حطوه معكم في شنطه يدك ومطلعه
المقصوره وساعه لا خلوه مع العفش او
الحقائب في تحت الطياره يعني
2010 مع البطاريات الليثيوم لما حصل برده
همم انفجار او حريق لاحد البطاريات
وبعديها بقى البطاريات الجسم والشواحن
المتنقله او الكبيره همم في الحالتين هو
مؤامره اصبح متروك لتقييم سلطات المطار
وشركات الطيران يعني سلطات المطار بيبقى
لها حدود معينه وشركات الطيران قادره ان
هي يكون لها هي كمان معينه الامر برده
اصبح غير مرتبط بالسلام الجويه فقط ولكن
اصبح دي بعد تجاري او يعني اقتصادي لان
يعني في البدايه لما كان الامر في ضعف
والشركات والمطارات اخذت قرار عدم صعود
البطاريات الليثيوم
الشواحن اثر اقتصاديا لان في ناس بقت مش
عايزه تسافر عليها وتسافر على حاجات ثانيه
نعم الناس انهارت ايه لانه يعني اللاب توب
بالاشياء التليفون كل شيء
في شركات ومطارات عملت ما هو اكثر عملته
على حسب قدره يعني
اذا كانت هتقدر يطلعها اكثر من 100 واكلها
تعامل معين في يعني تعددت بصراحه الطرق
ولم يكن هناك امر ثابت بس اعتقد ان بعد
هذا الحريق المسؤولين عن السلامه الجويه
في منظمات الطيران العالميه هيعملوا تحليل
مخاطر واعتقد ان في توصيات مهمه هتطلع في
الامر واعتقد ان التوصيه الاولى والاهم
انه لن يتم من السماح بشحن همم هذا الشاحن
على الطائره الافتراضيه اللي انا قلتها
صحيحه وهي اقرب
معانا في الطياره لاي درجه لازم نقلق من
الحدود هذا الشيء او احتماليه او فرضته
انا انا عندي اعتقاد مبداي ان هذا كمان ان
النوع او الجوده بتاعه الشاحن هي اللي ما
كانتش كويسه لان هي دي برده تكون عامل
مؤثر فهل نوع هيكون عليه دور هو طبعا بما
انه حادث
الطياره
الجويه بالتحليل المخاطر وبالتوصيات اللي
بتطلعها وهي يعني السبب الرئيسي هو اللي
هيبين لنا شكل التوصيات هتطلع ان شاء الله
كابتن محمود القطيار وخميس شكرا لك
طيب وعلى فكره الحادثه اللي شفتوها مو
الاولى الانفجار باور بانك علامه رحله
طيران ففي سنوات سابقه شهدنا حوادث مماثله
وفي شهر اكتوبر العام الماضي كان فيه
متداول مقطع فيديو الانفجار باور بانك في
مطار كازاخستان
طيب يعني احنا كمستخدمين الان ايش نعمل
كيف اللي معانا كويس وما يسبب نصيبه شيء
ما ينفجر او يعمل حريق صديق مع المحرر
التقني عبد الله السبع اعطانا الشرح
الكافي والوفي
البطاريات الاضافيه شيء نعتمد عليها بشكل
كبير في حياتنا الفتره الحاليه ليه لان
وقت السفر خاصه تكون طالع وتتمشى وغيرها
وتفضل بطاريتك وانت تصور وغير فتحتاج
البطاريه عشان تشحن جوالك عشان تكمل تصوير
وتنشر في ملفات توصل اجتماعيه المختلفه
لكن مش المشكله انك لو انت استخدمت بطاريه
تجاريه انه ممكن تنفجر باي لحظه ومش
تجاريه ايضا انها ممكن تتلف جوالك وتسبب
لك مشاكل في جوالك فلذلك اول شيء لازم
تحرص عليه استخدام البطاريه اصليه الشيء
الثاني البطاريات الاصليه لها عمر افتراضي
وايضا لازم تستخدمها بطريقه همم يعني ما
تكون همم شديد في استخدام هذه لانه ترميها
مثلا او شيء ممكن تسبب مشاكل همم وبعدها
ممكن تنكسروا ايضا بعدها ممكن تسبب حرائق
اذا سمح الله زي ما شفنا قبل همم فتره
بسيطه في بيوت طبعات ان عندهم صار عندهم
مشاكل حرائق او المقطع اللي كان الشخص
داخل الطياره وصار عندهم حرائق فلذلك
صححين البطاريات مفيده لكنها هي نقدر نقول
عنها ممكن تتحول الى قنابل موجوده لو ما
استخدمتها بشكل صحيح